hey folks a few more of these before  pride month is over and this time i want  to talk about  presentation what i mean by that well  easy explanation right now i am  presenting quite feminine  i don't always but increasingly i do but  something that i want you  and i mean this to members of the  lgbtqia plus  community as well nobody owes you  presentation  and no one needs to justify their  identity  through presentation non-binary people  do not have to present androgynously and  they do not owe anyone that  feminine people including trans feminine  people  are still trans women if they identify  as such  with stubble trans men  if they identify as men are still men  even if they do not wear a binder and  still have breasts  presentation is not identity